um so
the compulsory reminders
one is that
um there's the possibility of gathering
at gather town after the talk
i put the link in the chat
[Music]
let me discuss the protocol also before
we get started
so questions
as usual are welcome at any point
everybody should be able to speak
at this point because everybody has been
promoted to panelists
uh um it's still nice because people
might
join us attend this later if you're
sending a chat message
make sure um to send it to both
all send it to all panelists and
attendees because otherwise the
attendees won't see it
so you can ask questions in the chat
you are also and then i will try to read
it out to our speaker bart
at the first suitable moment but it's
also fine
and it's nice to have some interactivity
just unmute and and ask your question as
you would as in a regular seminar
[Music]
so i don't think i have anything else by
way of formalities this is
we've had different setups for different
talks today i think we're looking at
one seminar that is probably
so if i understood about correctly
roughly an hour or slightly more without
questions but of course we'll try to add
lots of questions
to make part speak with us for longer
but it's not like a clear first half
second half kind of thing it's more like
a unified seminar
probably um
and with that i'll do an extremely brief
um presentation of bart bart
who is at the freyja university brazil
which i'm not supposed to translate
that's the free university of brussels
so i didn't say that we had a
complicated discussion just a few
minutes of you for those who heard
that what the free university means and
there are apparently several free
universities in brussels in
different languages but bart is at vub
where he's interested in knowledge
representation all kinds of
at all kinds of levels for the sat
community
maybe one of bart's claims to fame would
be that he's one of the people behind
the sat solver with symmetry breaking
that
won the 2016 no limits track in a
breakaway fashion
but bart is not going to tell us about
that today
he is going to tell us about an
intriguing topic of
explainable constraint programming kind
of sort of and in order to
understand what that even means i'll
have to leave the word
to bart so please
so thank you jacob so indeed i will i
will talk about
a framework for explainable for
explaining how to solve uh
constrained satisfaction problems um
but i actually are you light maybe
unknowingly i will talk a little bit
about symmetry
uh in my introduction um because
when um i was first asked to to um give
a talk here at the beyond satisfiability
workshop i thought well
beyond satisfiability so where where
should the satisfiability community
go next in my opinion so what's
important
and and then i always think of um it's
this paper by peter stuckey at some
some workshop a couple of years ago i
think which was titled
uh there are no cnf problems so um
and what he meant by that was well there
are no problems that are
naturally in cnn or anything i mean
we're always encoding some problems at
some
higher level that arise more naturally
at a higher level we're encoding them as
cnf and we're developing very efficient
solvers for that
um and so
an obvious way for going beyond
satisfiability would be to adopt some
sort of high level modeling language
which which is done in typically in
constraint programming but in many other
disciplines as well
and the reason why is because when
solving set problems
we're actually missing um
structural information of the problem
often
and our work related to symmetry
breaking
really highlights this problem that what
we've been doing there
our main focus of the work was on
detecting structure in the problem
structure
that was there in the modeler's mind so
the people who were solving this problem
they knew that this structure was there
they modeled it
and then they they wrote some uh
encoding to cnf
and then the structure was lost and then
this this problem is given to a set
solver and it's asked well solve it
but i'm not going to tell you about the
structure and this is of course not the
efficient way to solve it
so we spent lots of time optimizing the
symmetry detection
figuring out that actually this cnn
encoding
is an encoding of some problem at some
higher level in which certain objects
are interchangeable
and this fact that there were some
interchangeable objects at a higher
level
allows us to get really good encodings
of the symmetry breaking constraints
compact encodings that have a very
strong breaking power
on the other hand if you would give a
solver instead of giving him the cnf
encoding
giving him give him a first order
representation of the
say a pigeonhole problem the
prototypical example of of this uh
symmetry breaking is pigeonhole
so if you would give the the solver
first order
version of it and you say well for all
pigeons there must exist a hole such
that the pigeon is in the hole and
for all holes and two couples and two
pigeons
if they're both in the same hole then
they must be equal and then you give it
a set of pigeons and a set of holes then
it's clear
for the solder that that this these
pigeons are interchangeable the holes
are interchangeable
and no detection is needed and and the
pigeon problem becomes very easy
so a good step forward for the set
community would be i think to adopt
a single uh higher level modeling
language but of course which one do we
need to choose and that's a
difficult question because this choice
is causing a lot of fragmentation
there's lots of different research
domains that go beyond sut
and and that well are using different
modeling languages but actually
using a lot of techniques from set
that's just my small message
and in today's talk you will see this
so my algorithms that i will discuss
will all be at a set level
so i will talk about propositional
theories and some algorithms for them
but the explanations that i will produce
will be at the first order level at the
kind of
types of constraints that you that you
would write in in the context of
constraint programming
and actually internally it also works
like this so we're
we're using this type of first order
constraints um
but we're grounding them we're reducing
them to
c enough but we still have the first
order constraints and the explanations
that we will
produce that we will give to the users
will be in terms of
the first order constraints so if at any
point during my talk
something is unclear about well
now you're showing me first order
formulas and then you're doing stuff
with propositional logic on the other
hand
uh if at a certain point the relation is
unclear just
interrupt me and we can go a bit deeper
into that
um but so i will switch between the two
levels sometimes
so that might might be confusing maybe
not um
so just interrupt me and actually that
holds for um
for anything else as well so if there's
any
questions feel free to interrupt me by
voice it's the most
efficient way of communicating it's much
faster than typing so
um and i i when i teach i already talked
to a
non-responsive screen way too long so um
just interrupt me so what's on the
agenda for today
um so i will present some actually a
quite young
research project we started somewhere
last year
uh to work on this and um
the the project was originally triggered
by the holy grail challenge
which it was a challenge at um a cp
workshop
um on progress towards the holy grail
and this challenge had to do with
solving
solving zebra puzzles and these are
zebra puzzles are
also known as einstein puzzles these are
puzzles in which you get some clues
i'll show some examples in a minute some
clues and have to match
certain entities together um so
the there was some challenge there we
tried to solve it and that's actually
what that
this whole pro to this whole project
that we're working on now
and um on well explaining
basically solutions of of cp problems
and um so i'll i'll talk a bit about
this challenge what the challenge was
what the puzzles are
and then i'll talk about our our
solution that we had for explaining them
which was stepwise explanations
this is published at akai last year and
then
in the later parts i will go into some
well unpublished work
um i will in in part 4
section four will be about the ocus
problem
which is somewhat similar to minimal
unsatisfiable subsets or smallest
uh minimal unsatisfiable subsets which
you might have seen occur somewhere
already
um this is work that's still under
review and then
in the fifth section i will talk about
nested explanations which is about
um explaining at different levels of
abstraction basically you could say or
or certain explanation steps that we
will produce in
section three might still look quite
difficult
and but we then want to zoom into this
to to really explain it in more detail
by means of some form of reasoning by
contradict
contradiction and then finally we will
conclude
so first about the holy grail challenge
um the holy grail challenge was about
logic grit puzzles
and in these puzzles you always have a
set of clues
set of clues are just sentences in
natural language
and you have a set of a
set of sets of entities so you have some
sets of entities and you need to link
these entities together
and so the most famous example coming
from einstein is about
a zebra and an englishman living in the
red house and
the spanish smoking cigars and the
um yeah one people living next one
person living next to another one now
you need to figure out all the relations
basically
and so each entity is linked to exactly
one entity of each other type
so for instance in this um i'll just
give an example in the next slide
and all the links are consistent and
this i will refer to as transitivity
and the fact that each entity is linked
to exactly one other
i will refer to as big activity so
here's a
small example it's about people
people who went to a restaurant together
they all had pasta so they had a
different type of pasta
each person had one type of pasta each
person had one sauce
and they also had to pay something they
had to pay a certain amount of money
and then there are some clues in natural
language such as well the person who
ordered capellini
paid less than the person who chose
arabiata sauce
the the one who ordered tagliolini paid
more than angie angie is one of the
persons so the one who had
tagliolini paid more than ng so we
already see that ng will
not have ordered tagliolini and so on so
there's a set of clues here
and if i as a human
want to solve this kind of puzzle
how would i work well typically these
puzzles also come with some sort of a
grid
let me zoom in a little bit so that you
can
read it well so typically they come with
some
sort of a grid here um
and you will start filling in things you
know in this grid you will start filling
in oh well
the person who ordered capalini paid
less than the person who chose arabiata
sauce so
definitely cappellini and arabiata sauce
will not be linked together
and you can put some crawls there the
one where tagliolini paid more than
angie
well if i use that clue there's lots of
stuff i can derive also
ng didn't order tagliolini you know so
ng
didn't order tagliolini and then i have
to find out where where that is
and she didn't order tagliolini um but
also
ng didn't pay the largest amount and so
the prices were 4 8 12 16 here
so ng cannot have paid the largest
amount and i can keep on doing this i
can keep on
filling my grid going over these clues
seeing what can i derive
basically i'm doing some sort of
propagation here and i'm
and sometimes i will also use
these implicit axioms for instance once
i have derived and this is now not
correct
or not necessarily once i have derived
that ng
didn't pay 8 12 or 16 i can drive rk in
that case she must have paid
for of course and then i'm using this
bijectivity constraint
and and if i want to use this kind of
transitivity constraint what i would say
is well angie
she paid for but she didn't take
tagliolini
so tagliolini cannot have cost four
so let me use my colors consistently so
tagliolini cannot have cost four
and so that means that these links are
consistent
if angie paid four and tagliolini
she didn't take tagliolini and it cannot
have been the tagliolini that was
that cost four euros
okay so um so these are the logic grid
puzzles
and then there was this challenge and
the challenge consisted of three parts
the first part was parse these puzzles
so do some natural language processing
parse the puzzles and translate them
into some
constrained satisfaction problem
automatically
the second challenge was solve this
constraint problem automatically and the
third problem was
explain actually i think it was stated
explain in natural language how to solve
this puzzle
so it was quite related to natural
language and but we were lucky we were
lucky because
a couple of years ago one of my master's
students
jen's class he had for his master thesis
worked on the problem of translating
logic grid puzzles from english into
first order logic
so step one basically we we got for free
when this challenge was announced
and step two well it's not really a
challenge
and these these puzzles they were made
for to be solved by humans
so solving them automatically for a
computer once you have a formulation
it's really no big deal uh so this was
also
solved so we um
focused on the explanation part
um by the way this parsing into natural
language
it's an interesting challenge our
solution was
not completely automatic i think there
was some tagging that
of certain words that that needed to be
done manually of the entity so there's
um it was mostly automatic but not
completely so there was some
intervention needed
um but i'm not going to focus on that
i'm not going to focus on the natural
language aspect
except for one thing that the
sometimes i might show you some of these
translations into logic and they might
really not look like what you want to do
what you want to do there
they will all use binary predicates they
will not use functions for instance
while actually this is a problem where
you're searching a lot of bijective
functions
um but we will make no assumption of how
they are represented i think if you if
you go tweak your representations you
can make everything much more efficient
but we didn't do that so we just started
from what the
natural language processing tool gave us
these logical sentences and we didn't
touch them anymore
um
we will see an example of that so our
focus was on this explanation
so how can you explain to a human how to
solve this puzzle and these explanations
are typically
well what we aimed for is basically what
i've been telling you
so we we aim for a kind of an
explanation
as well now you can use this clue
together with these previously derived
facts
to derive new facts in your grit and our
first version was in natural language
where all these arguments were given in
natural language because technically
that was a challenge
but it became very unreasonable
unreadable so
instead we went for a visual explanation
which is basically what i already showed
you
this grid here that gets filled in
automatically in which we then highlight
well
if you now use this clue or and then
there's in our in our interface that
i'll show later there's also you now use
this big activity or you use
you use this transitivity or sometimes
you even use
a combination of obvious activities and
transitivities
but every time we say well if you use
this clue or this implicit constraint as
we call it
and you use these previously derived
facts so maybe
i'll just show uh show an example so
this is
the same puzzle as we've been seeing
before um
the first thing he derives is the same
as what i what i did here i think
the person who ordered capellini paid
less than the person who chose arabiata
sauce
i know it's something else than what i
what i said but
um what you can also was that also my
first clue
oh yeah what you can also get from this
clue is that arabiata sauce cannot have
cost four
cannot have been the smallest the
smallest price
because um the person who ordered
capillini paid less than the person who
chose arabiata sauce
and we continue like that we highlight a
certain clue gives us
uh some information so this is exactly
the same as what i had said in my
explanation ng cannot have bought
tagliolini and ng cannot
have paid the most because of this clue
here
and it goes on a bit like this and after
a while you will see that you cannot
not just use the clues anymore but
sometimes you will say
these blue squares here they indicate
well i'm using this previously derived
fact
that a raviata sauce was paired with
farfalle
and i used the bijectivity constraint
here to derive that well if it was
paired with
farfalle then it was not paired with any
of the other pastas
so these are the kind of explanations we
produce and here's this transitivity
constraint it's always this triangular
pattern
where we say okay arabiatos also spared
with farfalle and claudia did not choose
a vietnam sauce so yeah she cannot have
eaten for vale
and it goes on like that and after a
while the explanations will get more
uh complicated um
but now let's formalize this okay so
i can show you explanations you can yeah
we won the challenge
but that's maybe not uh such a big big
thing to say because it was out of two
participants
so i i should also mention this of
course um
and i think the reason why we won is
because we had this um holistic solution
we tackled all the different pillars
thanks to this master student who had
already done most of the work for the
natural language part
so we saw the demo already
and basically what we're doing is i
already mentioned we're not going to
tweak the representation
we're also not going to modify the
underlying solvers
and we're also not interested here in
explaining
how the solver found the solution we're
not explaining you're not trying to
explain how a certain solver works
what we're aiming for is to find an
explanation
that is useful for the human and and the
human probably doesn't care that the
solver started
making some choices instead of
propagating or whatever he's been doing
and
the human knows his puzzles he doesn't
know any it doesn't need to know any
solving technology
we want to explain to him how to solve
the puzzle
so you can check this demo on the
website um
so after well
developing these ideas of what kind of
an explanation you wanted we
said okay we want to to formalize this
what is an explanation how can we
compute it
um and um
[Music]
yeah how can we guide the search for
these explanations
and demonstrate that it actually works
and that's roughly what we did in our
in our akai paper so
i will often use sigma to denote a
propositional vocabulary
and a partial interpretation is
a consistent set of literals over sigma
and sometimes i will also
identify this interpretation with a set
of unit clauses so i might write if t is
some propositional theory and i is an
interpretation i might just write
t and and i to denote the um
the new propositional theory consisting
of everything in t and then all the unit
clause of everything that's true in i
so a propositional theory is a set of
constraints i don't care if they're
if they're clauses or if you have some
other propositional constraints
um and so
again uh slightly abusing notation but
this is quite common i i don't think i
should say to this audience
a set of constraints i identify with the
conjunction of all of them
um if i say this um d and i
implies uh i prime it means that um
all models of this are more precise
than this so that all the information i
prime follows from what's in t
and what's in i so this is quite
standard
so now the goal of our
explanation problem is the following
or maybe i should say this these logic
grid puzzles they have the very nice
property
that they have a unique solution so the
there's
a single unique solution that's implied
by all of these clues
um and so our goal is given
a set of constraints t and maybe some
interpretation i we
grid puzzles that's the complete
solution
in other cases this might just be well
what can be derived by some very strong
propagation mechanism
so it's the intersection of the of all
the solutions it's
the um cautious consequence sometimes
called
um but so the
our goal is to explain how you can start
from t
and i and get to i end so
to this final and for the logic grid
puzzles nicely
and also for many other of this type of
puzzle game this is just nicely
the unique solution um
so the way we want to do it is we want
to
break this up this explanation in simple
steps
simple in between quotes i still have to
say what simple is
um we want to explain in simple steps
how to go from t
and possibly in an initial
interpretation already which
you can also assume to be part of t um
but
to go to um this cautious consequence
and our focus until now has always been
on single steps
on on saying okay what is an explanation
step
and um how can we compute good
explanation steps
that are simple in between quotes and
we're
not focusing on aspects of optimizing
the entire sequence yet
for instance for for humans it might be
much more logical to say to first derive
everything you can do with one
constraint before you jump to the second
one
so the order in which you derive certain
things
might be relevant for humans while um
we haven't been doing that yet so our
focus has been on
how can we find a next very simple step
to explain and then the next one and the
next one and then
chain it into a sequence question
yes are we always interested
in like facts which i guess in in
sat language are our unit clauses or or
can we derive
more complex like we know either this or
that or no
we're looking at um we're looking at at
uh well unit clauses or facts here to
explain
no disjunctive knowledge no complicated
knowledge
um actually you could play with that i
mean
um by introducing by changing your your
language
you could introduce a new variable that
represents some some form of disjunctive
knowledge
and in that case you could you could go
derive it but we went for the facts
because
it's very easy to to visualize and
basically
you could also not just
you could also restrict your vocabulary
on which you're allowed to explain so
depending on the
we don't really do it yet currently um
well technically we do it but it's not
so visible
uh so i'll and that has to do with my my
very first remark
um but so you could restrict your
vocabulary of
even which literals you're allowed to
use in your explanation which ones
you're allowed to derive
and which one's not and the reason why
you
might want to do it is because um this
what we do is we have this first order
logic representation and we reduce it to
start by grounding
but that will introduce lots of
auxiliary variables and
and these variables we don't want to go
using our in our explanations because
the user doesn't know them he doesn't
know what variable 20
507 means so going giving an explanation
of the form well now we can derive
variable 20507
it's not very useful for the user so we
only want to explain it
in terms of things he can understand
so in our case the things he can
understand
we decided for the logic grid puzzles
it's the grit so the only thing
that you can use for these puzzles in in
your
language of explanation if you want are
facts like this is true in the grid or
this is false integrity things you can
actually mark and degrade these are the
things we
as a human would probably also um be
reasoning with
um
so yes only effects um
but if you have a smart user who knows
about
disjunctions or stuff like that you can
change your vocabulary and also allow
for
these new facts to be used in your
explanations
so now formally what do we mean by
an explanation step so if we have at a
certain moment
found this interpretation here i
i minus one and we want to go to the
a more precise one that has a bit of
extra effects in it i
i and the next one in the in the
sequence we say that well
how can we explain this step from i
minus one to i
by a triple we say we explained by a
triple where
ni are just the newly defined facts
um we have them in the triple because
they're sometimes useful
but mainly so what's really explaining
it is well we in order to go from here
to there
we have some certain previously derived
facts that we're using
and there is a typo this should be i
minus one i see
so we have some facts from the previous
step what we already had derived so far
that we were using
we say we're using a certain subset of
the clues
so clues and implicit constraints are in
t so we're using a subset of those
and well they should be so that
indeed that subset plus these
um previously the right facts entail
everything that's new
of course this is a very useless
definition still
this is just basically giving some
correctness criterion of when we say
that indeed
these subsets explain something um
so we probably want to do something
better than that we
we want to look at non-redundant
explanation steps
and a non-redundant explanation step is
basically one that you cannot shrink
anymore
saying that well if i would have some
some subset of my previously derived
facts that i'm using
and some subset of my constraints that
i'm using
and that still explains this derivation
well then it must be so that
they um are equal i cannot have any
strict subsets
that's some form of non-redundancy and
that's already
good but it's probably not enough
and maybe here's the first observation
that so if we're interested in computing
these non-redundant explanations
we can actually use an existing
technique
a minimal unsatisfiable core or minimal
unsatisfiable subset extraction
because there's a nice correspondence
between minimal unsatisfiable course
of a certain theory and non-redundant
explanations
of oh there's another minus one missing
here
i was a bit sloppy it seems um
so there's a nice correspondence between
minimal unsatisfiable course and
non-redundant explanations
namely if
that we have a minimal unsatisfiable
core of this here
this says well what i previously had and
that's
another minus one um so
lots of of by one errors it seems if
what we previously had and the theory
and
not l so not the literal the negation of
the literal we want to derive
minimal unsatisfiable course of this
first of all they will always
since we're working in a satisfiable
setting they will always contain not
l this minimal unsatisfiable course
and whatever they contain of of
i i minus 1 and t exactly forms a
non-redundant explanation
to go from i uh um okay
no here my minus ones were not really
needed because because here i
just had my next one was
i i union l so here it was actually okay
on this slide
so i will start over
minimal unsatisfiable course of this
theory on the left
correspond to non-redundant explanations
to go
to derive one new literal l
and that was an observation that was
quite handy for us because
the um the tool we were working with
that's the idp system
um that supports first order logic and
grounds into sub basically
it's it already supported minimal
unsatisfiable core extraction as well so
here was something we could work with
any questions about this correspondence
is it clear or should i explain this in
a bit more detail
okay i assume it's clear um but
just come back to it if it's uh needed
at some point
um so i already set this non-redundant
non-redundancy it's probably not good
enough
we will assume some cost function and
what that cost function has to be
we don't really know it but we just
assume some generic cost function
that quantifies how um interpretable
an explanation is because for instance
in these in these logic grid puzzles
you could easily get very bad um minimal
um or non-redundant explanations if you
have something like
well this here
eight is linked to arabiata sauce and
farfalle is linked to arabiata sauce
well the obvious thing to do as well
for instance then um
eight is linked to farfalle because of
one transitivity constraint
but actually you could you you could
also get this indirectly
because of using five other transitivity
constraints together
um and that's not the kind of
explanation you want you want the one
with the one transitivity constraint
that just directly says this
transitivity constrained together with
these two effects
gives you this new effect um
so non-redundancy gives us bad stuff
still so we need some cost function
and so what we're aiming for then is to
produce
some sequence that starts with
some initial interpretation and that
derives at each
each point um a new
interpretation that's and this is the
explanation of why it follows from i
zero
some sequence and we want to minimize
some aggregate over the sequence
and for now i said we're not really
working on optimizing the sequence as a
whole yet so we're basically
what we're now minimizing is the the the
hardest step in the sequence
um but there's lots of room to to to
play with that as well
and how do we do this well i already
mentioned we have minimal unsatisfiable
subset extraction
so let's our first our first uh bet to
solve this was let's just
try to use it and what we did was at
so i'm showing you here how to compute a
single step so we have arrived at a
certain interpretation i
we have this theory here we want to get
eventually to
i ant and we have this cost function
here and
what we're saying is well we'll just go
over all of our literals that we still
need to derive
we will compute some a non-redundant
explanation
or a minimal unsatisfiable subset of how
we could derive this single literal
and we will just pick the best of them
and let's hope it works
and of course um we ended up if if we
really just do that
we we saw this is this is sometimes
giving terrible things because of the
kind of
um phenomenon that i just mentioned that
sometimes he picks
uh five transitivity constraints which
indeed form a minimal set
but there's actually one that would be a
much better fit
so um
and and also um yeah
this this minimal unsatisfiable subsets
here
this guarantees that we will find
something non-redundant but we really
have no guarantee about a cost
so we're just hoping that that we
accidentally find a good one
we could solve this by enumerating the
muscles or
by optimizing them and that's actually
what i will talk about later
um so for now what we see is well we
have a guarantee of non-redundancy
it doesn't really guarantee quality and
in our eki paper
we basically worked with the tools we
had and tried to optimize this as much
as possible
so to have some heuristic workarounds
that
actively go search for smaller sets of
constraints that could derive something
but i will not go into the details
because i think by now we have better
solutions
so um
details are in the akai paper
so what else what else we did back then
is um
we implemented this of course and we
have some visual
explanation interface i already showed
it to you and we also
made up a cost function for these logic
grid puzzles
and the we put some numbers on it
because
yeah if you want a concrete cost
function you have to do that but these
are really just magic
magic constants right for instance i
think we we said that well
using a single um implicit axiom like a
bijectivity constraint costs five
why five because it just seemed to
suitable to us
it's future work to to really um
evaluate um what's difficult or what's
what's conceived simple and difficult
for a human but this is really something
we didn't focus on
so we just said okay using a single
implicit axiom is very cheap
using a single constraint together with
some implicit axioms is
less cheap and using multiple
constraints
or multiple implicit axioms is very
expensive
of course if you if i show you this list
you might wonder why not use a single
constraint without any implicit axioms
because we've been doing it all the time
but actually it turns out that because
of this and that's a side effect of
having no control over over the the
encoding
um it almost never happens that you can
use a single constraint without implicit
axioms
for instance from this
clue the person who ordered capellini is
either daemon or claudia
you could immediately a humans who could
say well only using this clue i can
immediately derive
that angie didn't order capalini
because it must be damon or claudia but
our translation that we got
this first order logic translation says
there is some person who ordered
capellini and who is either daemon
or claudia this in itself didn't
doesn't entail that angie didn't order
capellini
it only entails it in case you have this
big activity constraint or at least one
direction of it for ordered
that there's only one person who ordered
capellini
and and in this case if you know okay
there's only one person who ordered
catellini
and either damon or claudia or aditya
then angie cannot have ordered it
so practic and this is something that
um constantly occurs and of course
this in natural language this is kind of
implicit in the
the person the person who ordered
capalini
and here is saying there is some person
who ordered capolini
but this translation is fine for logic
grid puzzles because
another translation that would have been
fine would have been this for all
all persons who ordered who ordered um
cappellini
are either daemon or claudia would have
been equally
equally good um
but this is the one the system the nlp
tools producer this is the one we work
with
and we noticed um this really doesn't
propagate very well
so you really you almost always need to
use implicit constraints as well
i already mentioned this we use the idp
system under the hood
and that's roughly the summary
of the ekai paper um
i don't know if you're jumping ahead but
would a
tool would you be able to figure out
that angie didn't order this
or would you not well so the tool would
figure it out but would say it follows
from this clue
together with the fact that um
for all uh p1 p2
um and then pasta let's call it
something to eat and
an e ordered p1
e and ordered so this is one of the the
transitivity constraints that he has
oh no sorry the big activity constraints
p1 equals p2
so he has these these big activity
constraints as well and then he would
say okay from this clue together with
actually
one bite activity constraint i can
figure it out
okay thanks
so um
either we can take a short break now or
i can just continue
i see it's well been 45 minutes
something so we we could take a five
minute break or ten minute break and
then
i could continue this would be an okay
moment to split the talk into
uh it's like you wish basically
then i say since we're usually taking
our breaks a bit
late why don't we take a 10 minute break
now so we'll re-convene
uh like 27 minutes
past the hour but of course before i
mean any questions there have
hasn't been much by way of questions in
the chat but this is a good moment to
speak up
any questions comments on what part i've
said so far
please don't hesitate
so um we don't see anything in the chat
right now i guess we'll just
see if if anything accumulates during
the break otherwise
uh 27 minutes past the hour we'll
reconvene and
continue the seminar
thank you so much
so we should get started again in like a
couple of minutes
yes it's an interesting question what uh
what the psychologically correct
cost function should be
yeah it's it's probably a very hard to
answer question and very personal but
um yeah i have to
you have to show your puzzles to small
kids and then measure
how many seconds they look at the clues
and uh filled in grid point
and then you know depending on that you
decide how deep
the truth was yeah and then well of
course
for for adults it's maybe something else
that's uh easier another question is
yeah sorry there's
someone at st andrews who's doing a phd
on
um how humans solve sudoku puzzles
and she's recording people solving
specially crafted puzzles and looking at
the logical steps they're making doing
things like eye tracking to
to see which constraints they're looking
at
that's uh possibly provides an answer to
this
i mean i use a lot of binary i'm not a
sudoku master i do
use a fair number of binary clauses like
you know i for this square by the time i
nail it down to okay it's either two or
a five
here and the two or the five will be in
either one of these two guys
yeah so so i think what the first thing
she established was that
anyone who knew about constraint
programming or sat solving um
would immediately have to be an invalid
experimental participant
oh but it's
it looks like humans do very high levels
of consistency but only
locally um so they they don't write
anything down but they can look at
several constraints simultaneously and
reason against those constraints long as
it doesn't involve really remembering
anything except deletions
i mean another question is also if you
want to measure somehow the depth of
facts like you could say because somehow
the more
the more clues i have used in order to
reach a point where
this sudoku cell is filled with a you
know a seven if i use
if this comes at the very end then maybe
somehow i'm less confident because i
you know the first like conclusions are
so obvious but then when i'm starting
building on my own previous conclusions
then what if i screwed up somewhere
yeah and and what also plays a role i
think is
if you really want to use this for
explaining is is um
that in the beginning of your
explanations certain things will be
quite hard to understand while
by the time you're at the end people
will have seen these patterns and will
see
okay they will start to they will start
to see it differently they will
start to understand more so you might
you might get away with taking
bigger steps more towards the end of the
sequence
um can you capture symmetry i guess you
can
but using the encoding you can capture
stuff like symmetry like okay
by the same reasoning we just used you
can i can apply it over here and the
same thing follows
yeah possibly or um but
there are also sometimes i i think i
have an example here somewhere
yeah this here is an example of some
kind of a pattern that the first time i
had to look at a bit
why is he concluding this and then but
once you see it
the next time will be quite easy so
what you see here is in this step is
that
so damon cannot have taken farfalle and
rotini
and 16 can all have been cappellini or
tagliolini
so basically if if daemon would be
paired to 16 then there would be no
options left for
a type of pasta and visually this
is basically you have the entire row
filled with negations somewhere but
part of them with daemon part of them
with 16 so daemon cannot go together
with 16.
and that actually uses several
bijectivity and
and and one transitivity constraint
um but yeah once you've
once you've had this kind of an
explanation once and you see okay these
rows
basically it's a complete a complete row
of minuses if we merge them
the next time it's it's obvious that
this is correct but
um the first time it at least took me a
while to see
what's going on here um
yeah so paul william is suggesting in
the chat we should crowdsource you
should
put out i don't know tons of
explanations on what mechanical turk can
have them scored
yeah um
of course the question is how deep you
want to go on these puzzles
but we've been thinking about it about
how to
easily figure out what's the right or or
what are easy
explanations i think our magic numbers
came up with something
quite okayish but far from well
the actual if it even exists on the
actual um
cost of such things so
we should get started but let's just
give
the chat still seems to be silent
but anyone else who wants to grab the
moment to ask a question before we
ask bart to get started again please
write something in the chat or just
speak up
otherwise i guess we'll
just ask part two continue
so yeah i think let's just continue then
all right just interrupt me if something
uh shows up uh some question
so um the next section so
we took a step back we said okay these
are the kind of explanations we want
um we have some mechanism to compute
them but it's actually not really
computing
optimal ones with respect to our
made up cost function so let's take a
step back
what do we really want we actually um
let me just put this full screen we
actually
want to go beyond these minimal
unsatisfiable subsets
to um compute something better and when
we looked into the literature what
existed
there was already some work on
optimizing
such minimal unsatisfiable subsets on
finding
a smallest miss uh that's what the s
stands for
which searches for cardinality minimal
uh
minimal unsatisfiable subsets there was
nothing yet on
optimizing them but optimizing them
seems quite
close to the existing work so
our first step was well let's look at a
new problem
an optimal unsatisfiable subset so we
have some arbitrary
well arbitrary we have some some
function
um some cost function given um for
instance some linear cost function
and we want to optimize we want to find
an optimal unsatisfiable subset
meaning we want we have some formula
and on this slide yes i so the
the d and i the i is already considered
to be part of the the t here we just
have some formula
we want to find an unsatisfiable subset
of it
so s is a subset of t it must be
unsatisfiable and all
other unsatisfiable subsets should have
at least as high
cost um that's our goal once we have
that um
so we still have to solve how how can we
compute these optimal unsatisfiable
subsets but it turned out to be quite a
minimal
um modification of existing algorithms
um but once we have them we can modify
our algorithm for one step instead and
say well
let's go over all the literals that we
want to derive for each of them find
an optimal explanation basically an
optimal unsatisfiable subset
of of um this here
and pick the best one
and then we have suddenly have the
guarantee of optimality
we can wonder how big a difference does
it make in practice to go to
optimal unsatisfiable subsets versus
minimal ones
and but actually if we if we look at
this algorithm we're actually
probably doing a lot of work way too
often
um because all of these so
all of these calls to this new um
thing for that searches for an optimal
unsatisfiable subset
have a very similar theory so they get
as input
that something almost the same except
for one literal
um of a difference and we're doing this
over and over again in this loop so
probably
there has to there we thought at that
point there has to be some way to
exploit this this even more the fact
that we're doing
so many calls on very similar stuff
um what can we do with it
what's the question and so essentially
if we look at it what we want to do is
instead of
for each possible literal that we could
still derive
searching an explanation and this is
this explanation corresponds to some
unsatisfiable subset
so what you're actually interested in is
well given some formula this formula
here
this now says uh so my clues hold
whatever i
have derived so far holds and um
um why is there
this junction here this should be a
conjunction sorry
um this should have been a big end so
conjunction over all the possible
literals that we can still derive of the
negation of that literal
we want to find an unsatisfiable subset
of this
with a special property that it contains
exactly one of those literals
not l that's what we want
so what we're actually describing here
is a problem
where we want to find an unsatisfiable
subset of some formula
that satisfies certain meta-level
constraints
certain structural constraints about
which formulas can be included together
and which cannot be included together
and that's optimal with respect to a
certain function
and we call this problem ocus
and stands for optimal constrained
unsatisfiable subset
so constrained as in we're now imposing
meta constraints about which subsets are
acceptable and which are not
and the oh yeah of course stands for
optimal optimal
so optimality now means among those
subsets
con satisfying the p
it's optimal
and once we have suppose that we now can
somehow find
some magic black box that solves the
focus problem
computing an explanation a single step
becomes very easy because it's actually
the entire algorithm is just one well
the entire computation of
a single step is just a single call to
ocus emberdom
so um our life is um
from the explanation point of view we're
happy now
except that now we have a new problem to
solve which is this ocus problem so how
can we
efficiently generate focuses of a given
formula or or theory
and um there we took inspiration from
existing hitting set-based algorithms
so hitting set-based algorithms they're
quite popular in in max ad solving
and also for finding unsatisfiable
smallest unsatisfiable subsets
and they're all based on on the
following uh
duality um saying that
well so this theorem talks about
minimal correction sets and a correction
set
is something that you have to remove
from a theory to make it satisfiable so
t
is unsatisfiable and it's basically a
correction set is the complement of a
satisfiable subset
and what is and and this also
talks about the the muscles the minimal
unsatisfiable subsets
so a set is a minimal correction set
even only if it's a minimal hitting set
of the unsatisfiable subsets or of the
minimal unsatisfiable subsets
and it's a it's a mus it's a minimal
unsatisfiable subset even only if
it's a minimal hitting set of the
correction sets
and this duality is often used in in
algorithms that basically
alternate some call to some hitting set
solver that
if if you're trying to find for instance
the smallest moose
you're you're building up a set of
correction sets uh
you you do a lot of set calls and you're
building up a set of correction sets and
then you
do use a hitting set solver to to well
to find the minimal hitting set of that
and then you see
look oh is this now unsatisfiable if yes
i'm happy then i find found a smallest
miss
if not i keep on going
so yeah that this is the duality that
lies at the basis of many um
um mexican and smooth algorithms
so we started from that duality and
tried to solve the yogus problem with it
and this is
basically so um the extension of
of what i just described in words to um
this is our hitting set algorithm to
compute occurs and
so what we're doing is this h here is
um a set of correction subsets
of t so it's initialized to be empty
and um so it's a and we will just
keep track of a set of correct
correction subsets of t
and what we constantly do is we assume
that we can
compute some hitting set of h that is
optimal with respect to f and that
satisfies a certain
integrity constraint b and this p
is just exactly the the kind of meta
constraint that we wanted
so h so
um in practice we will use we will use
an uh
an ilp solver here a linear programming
but you could you could use a set solver
here as well
um depending on how you're going encode
this function f and this this predicate
p
um so we compute some hitting set of age
satisfying certain constraints
and
then we check is this hitting set
satisfiable yes or no if it's
unsatisfiable
then we have the guarantee that we found
a nocus that we found
an unsatisfiable subset that's optimal
with respect to f and that satisfies
this p
if not ignore line seven for a moment
if not we just say okay well then it is
satisfiable
so its complement is actually
a correction um subset not necessarily
minimal but that doesn't matter its
complement is a correction subset
so we add it to h and we continue
yeah by adding the complement we get a
guarantee that the next time
to have a hitting set of h we will not
get the same anymore and this keeps on
going until we find an ocus if one
exists at least
this here um this grow method is
something that's often
well it's something optional so it's
there's the opportunity here
to not just use this specific s that we
found
but to extend it into something larger
that's still satisfiable
um i will come back to this
in when i discuss different uh possible
possibilities for this grow but
so there's this option to to still
extend us
um and well with respect to correctness
uh there
um so the property that we're using to
show correctness is well
if you find some meeting set so if you
have any set of correction subsets
of of t so you have a set of
i didn't want to erase this a set of
correction subsets of t
h and you have some hitting set of h
so some set that contains at least one
element of each of the correction
subsets and if that hitting set is
optimal among the hitting sets
satisfying p whatever p
is then as
and furthermore as is unsatisfiable then
this is indeed an occurs and
no better one can exist and slightly to
our surprise we're actually
not using any kind of monotonicity
properties when we when we
when we first wanted to prove this we
had we had in mind that we
had to use certain monotonicity
properties of p
and f and actually in the reviews also
we we noticed a couple of reviewers
being surprised hey you don't have this
but
i checked it and it indeed seems to work
without monotonicity properties
so there is something this theorem
might be slightly stronger than it seems
at first
um and
yeah this case
it doesn't really happen in our in our
explanation situation but
in case uh h happens to have no waiting
sets because you
just have a very bad b or something um
then of course d has no
focuses so and this these together
guarantee that
the algorithm indeed works so this is
actually not a major modification of
of the existing algorithms what we do
basically is we
push the costs function and we push this
predicate we put just push it all down
to the
solver taking care of finding hitting
sets
and by and and that's it so if we
just remove this cost optimal and this
fmp you get some
generic uh hitting set-based algorithm
for doing something with unsatisfiable
subsets
and so we can we can just push them down
this function this predicate we just
push it down to the solver
responsible for the hitting sets um
and then there were some further ids and
these these further ideas that we had
were well
first of all we're not just doing one
call to ocus
and we're doing one call for a single
step but in the next step
we're gonna do another call to this
focus and then again and again and again
we're gonna keep on doing this until we
have this complete solution
and actually this second call will
probably be very similar to the first
call
how can we reuse information from the
first call that that's
what we wanted to to um to solve
and then there's this group this grow i
i said
okay i just left it open for now i said
we can have some methods we can have
some max out call or we can have
something that
that extends this satisfiable subset to
a larger
one and there's a trade-off between how
much time do i want to spend in it
because the larger we can make this s
the better it is the the more it
constrains our hitting sets
but we don't want to spend too much time
in it so there's a bit of a
a trade-off there as for incrementality
well the obvious way to do it is well
let's just keep our rh
but keeping our h so the h
consists of
correction sets of t um
so we can if the next time
we would be calling this ocus with
exactly the same t then we could just
call
keep the h but what's actually
um gonna happen is that we're constantly
changing the t a bit
in the sense that in the first the first
time we say well we start with t
and then um and the negation of
everything in i end
the negation of everything in i end and
the next time we might have derived
one literal already and we do it with t
and l
and the negation of everything in i end
except for l
and the next time every time one or more
literals move basically
switch polarity in our call
but so we're doing it with very similar
theories and actually
what we can in order to reuse as much
information as possible
we can just view this as
as if we're always using the same theory
and namely this one everything in d
everything in i end and everything
in uh the negation of i end but we play
with our p
say well in the first call you're simply
not allowed to select any of these in
your okus and in the second call
you're not allowed to select the
negation of this l anymore
but you're allowed to select the l but
in and in that case we can just reuse
whatever whatever is in h so in the next
calls
so since we know in advance what our
complete
theory might be we can use this in
if you want to do this in slightly more
generality
the the trick is not to keep track of
your correction sets but to keep track
of your satisfiable subsets
because they will always remain valid
even if you change your theory
you can just take the intersection of a
satisfiable subset with your new theory
and that will still be satisfiable
because you're only making it smaller so
if you
if you want to use this incrementality
in a different setting
you have to focus on the satisfiable
subsets and not their complement um
and then i already mentioned there's the
um
the grow that we that we didn't really
talk about yet
um and so
this i wrote on my previous slide
already we have this theory we have this
i
ant and we have this complement of i end
and now we have some subset of this
how will we grow it how will we take
will we take
all three of them into account or not um
um and what about the cost function will
we take that into account somehow for
growing
and are we then interested in in
um growing it to something with a small
cost or with a large cost actually these
were all questions that we
we didn't really know there were
arguments to make for for lots of it
for for several of them uh our options
of them so we just
write lots of options out um and
um the option that that worked best we
will come to the experiment soon is
when growing we we basically
aim for something that's close to the
actual solution of the
um of the
the puzzle meaning so we do a call
to we want an unsatisfiable subset
we find some s subset of this that turns
out to be satisfiable
but that contains at least one of these
i and
bar literals so at least one wrong
literal
what we then did is well let's try a
maxset call
that extends this subset as much as
possible
but it focuses on maximizing
what's correct what makes making these
true and making these true that's the
option that that worked best
and the reason it worked best i think is
because
we were using um
because basically it was very easy to
always find the same solution for the
set solver
something that's very close to it um
yeah making this grow call
not too expensive but still getting
quite large subsets anyway
and and i think that was somewhat
balancing the trade of
the cost function we didn't really see
any um
i don't really have any interesting
remarks about that we tried different
versions as you will see on the
experiments but
there's not a lot to be learned there
that i i
or that we saw at least
so we implemented this building on
bisat and something that's now known as
cpm pi and that used to be known as cp
pi but for some reason that had to do
with
packages got a new name
so um
yes what cpp does is it allows an
integration of of writing your cp
constraints
with python with python data structures
um
and then it automatically reduces the
problem to set so it does the grounding
okay so but we we implemented this and
then we wanted to test a
certain uh we had a certain question
certain questions we wanted to see
answers to so first of all we
we wondered the step from minimal
unsatisfiable subsets to optimal ones
uh how does this influence the quality
of the explanations
i mean in practice then of course in
theory we know we can
we will only get better and but how much
better do we get does it really make
that big a difference or not
so that's the first thing we tested then
we compared these different
group methods that i talked about
we also tested the difference between
having this constraint version
that has a single call in each in each
step versus a non-constrained version
and we wondered does
reusing uh these satisfiable subsets
does it significantly um influence our
efficiency or not i mean is it important
to reuse them or not for these
explanations in particular as for the
solution quality it's plotted here um so
what this should be should have been
used here is probably a cost of
50 or something for uh or 50 or 60
for um using a single clue i guess that
was used here
and um
probably a single implicit constraint
and probably 100
i guess for using a
clue i don't remember the exact numbers
but what we see is that we find quite
some
instances that are um where explanations
are produced that are
very um much more so where
the good explanations are simply not
found by dismiss-based explanations
generation so it really pays off to do
uh optimal unsatisfiable substance
as for the grow what we basically have
is
here is three groups of algorithms
these are the ones that use a max set
call in the way i explained it before
uh so what they try is to to
maximize what's called actual stance
here for
um finding a satisfiable substance
that's that's as
close to the actual solution as possible
and this here tries to maximize
uh the full uh takes the entire theory
everything
and just tries to find as large as
possible unsatisfiable subsets of the
entire theory
so notice to make the distinction
between these two we're really using
domain specific knowledge
really using the fact that we're working
with these puzzles that we know that
certain constraints together
are um easy to satisfy many of them and
it's easy to satisfy many of them while
these other constraints which are than
the negations of the the
final literals they basically mess up
our solutions of the the first
constraint so
this distinction is is nothing generic
it's specific for the explanations
um and then there's some greedy method
that just tries to
to grow the um the satisfiable subset by
adding constraints
um yeah so it's set base lots of set
calls in there
um and what we noticed is like i
mentioned that these ones
perform better and there's this last
thing the distinction between these
three is which kind of kind of cost
function
i think the one that performed best was
just giving a uniform cost and ignoring
the
the cost function that was given all
together um
but i don't really have a solid
explanation for why that would be better
so just showing it here and then if we
compare the different
setups so using either
ocus or so the constraint version or the
the non-constrained version that just
has this loop and computes
lots of oses and either incremental or
non-incremental
and this is the the most based solving
um
so first of all notice this is not a
fair comparison
um these these four
here are computing the same thing
they're computing
a sequence that's in which every step is
optimal and this last one is not so this
has an easier job at least
and what we're basically seeing is that
we even outperform with this
constraintness these are these two lines
we
we
outperform the muse-based optimization
which is somewhere in between the
constrained and the non-constrained
version
what we also noticed is that this
incrementality
it has some effect not so much for
for um this occurs based solving but
if we do the same trick with the
incrementality with the
the non-constrained version we
didn't notice anything any difference
basically it doesn't make a difference
there whether you do
um this incremental solving or not um
this is also something we still have to
look uh further into
i mean
intuitively it would make sense that
that we would see this kind of
benefits from from this incrementality
because we're really doing lots of the
same computations over and over again so
it's a bit strange to not see this show
up in in always and we're still looking
for an explanation for that or
well but maybe it's just a bad benchmark
set that we need to expand it that's
that's also possible um
but that's roughly the summary of the
experiments in in this section
um yes so any questions about
this ocus-based explanations
or about the experiments
okay then i'll go to the to the next
part one question actually so i was
getting a
i guess yeah so i'll need another
review of this to fully grock everything
but
it seems to me that so when you're
computing are you computing the
explanations like one fact
at a time ah i know that's
something actually choosing which one is
the cheapest one to get next
or because it's somehow i mean i maybe i
misunderstood it but
it seems to me like there might be like
locally some explanations seem
cheap to get but if i took another route
then i would
you know the overall cost of getting all
the explanations
might have been less expensive or i
don't i don't know if the question makes
sense
um so um so there's
two things so there were or maybe more
than two things i want to
to say about this but so we're computing
the explanation say
one fact at a time in between quotes but
when we're explaining effects
we explain everything we immediately
explain actually
we actually in our explanation we will
derive more than one fact
we will derive all facts that follow
from the same clue for instance
if you say i can derive fact one using
only clue one and bijectivity constraint
one
but from these two actually a lot more
follows then we immediately derive
everything else that follows from them
as well because they it has the same
cost anyway and it's using the same
information so why not just do it all at
once
um for instance
a very silly example if there's a clue
saying
jakob has paid five euros that we then
immediately also derived that he
he didn't um or maybe jakob didn't pay
more than five euros
that we will not go give one explanation
that says he didn't pay one
and then in the next step oh he didn't
pay two for exactly the same reason
because so that we do in one step so you
drive multiple literals at once
and what we do every time is really we
compute
the cheapest step at least in the os and
ocus based
implementations we really compute the
cheapest
next step that's possible or a cheapest
next step that that's possible
because there can be multiple um among
all the possible literals to explain so
that's really the goal
this gives us the guarantee that our
final sequence will be optimal with
respect to uh
the worst cost that's occurring in the
sequence
but of course there might be i mean
it might be possible that if you at a
certain moment
have that you have the option between
basically a sequence that has
cost four four four four four all the
time and a five in the end
versus a sequence that starts with one
cost five and then gets super cheap
afterwards
because once you have done this hard
step everything is easy
and we're not making this distinction
yet so we will our algorithm will find
this sequence
it will start greedily from the start
and see
what's the next cheapest what the
cheapest thing i can derive now
and and in that case this will be a four
and it will keep on finding all these
cost four steps and then
say in the end okay yeah but now i'm
forced to do this very expensive step
of course five um that i could already
do in the beginning
um so we're not optimizing this yet
yes i see okay it makes sense uh but
you're right that okay so one thing is
that
i guess monotonicity with like learning
new facts cannot make anything else more
expensive i guess that's
but it could all i mean it also goes to
the i guess the question we had during
the break about psychology because one
you could also optimize for somehow
shallowness of explanations maybe like
you know
how how how many
like yeah how many derivation steps do i
need
to reach the deepest fact and maybe then
like a shallow explanation is easier to
follow for a human than one that
just gets one fact at the time in a very
very long chain or something but i
i guess that's like a a slight detour
and the main topic of what you've been
talking about
yeah actually it might be related to
what i will come to next to this
what we call nested explanations um
so so maybe i'll just
start talking about that and then we
will see that shallowness or or
something similar uh
show up there um because i think in the
break
when you were talking about this
shallowness you're
you i don't think you you really meant
it was in the context of sudoku and i
don't think you really
meant like how deep it is to solve the
entire sudoku puzzle
but often when people saw sudoku puzzles
they they they have their grit
and they start making certain
assumptions what if this were a one
or maybe mentally what if this were a 1i
yet then this has to be a 2
and then this has to be a 3 and then a
4.
ah but this is not possible so my
original
assumption that this is a 1 was wrong so
this cannot be a 1.
and in this case if you have to do this
mental process of
remembering lots of stuff and and
then to conclude but it cannot be a one
the longer the sequence is
the more um well
the harder it becomes to really be sure
that that this couldn't have been a one
in the first place
um and let's just get to the asset
explanations
because it this kind of reasoning is
actually what we're uh doing there
there was a question in the chat also i
don't know if soham wants to
ask it i try to
give permission to speak otherwise i'll
read it from the chat
i i don't see it i see a q a but is
there maybe a chat
and a different other so the question in
the chat reads as follows so
so would the algorithm only find the
lowest point in respect to the current
state
also is there another method of
visualization
for this problem
um so would the
algorithm only find the lowest point so
indeed so what we search for or what we
did this far is
given a certain state a partially filled
in grid
find the cheapest next step and of
course you can chain them
or find a cheapest next step and of
course you can chain them to get a
complete sequence of explanations
but it's quite greedy and and each step
is just
locally there's no coordination over the
entire sequence yet
and are there other methods of
visualization
well probably there are but this is
actually these grids that we have
are actually quite uh common in these
in these books that have floodgrid
puzzles the grid is often just drawn
next to it already
so that you don't have to do it yourself
so it's it's there and it's the
the common way of visualizing these kind
of puzzles
um which is why we why we chose this as
an
explanation mechanism and not natural
language because
in natural language these this kind of
explanations
because of this clue and the fact that
there's only one
this tends to get quite long and
unreadable
um
okay yeah
so for the nested explanations what we
noticed
is that um even with our cost function
some steps were still quite difficult
and of course you might say
yeah but that's maybe because you have a
bad cost function um
but the puzzle i showed you um so this
pasta puzzle
it's an interesting one because it was
actually sent to us by someone
who um knew that this master student of
mine had been working on
automatically translating them into into
logic and solving them automatically
and he he had been trying to solve this
puzzle from a newspaper or something
and he couldn't find a solution and he
wondered is it even a correct puzzle so
that was his question is this puzzle
even correct and can you explain it to
me
so if you try to solve it yourself at
some point i'll take the time for it
you'll see that there are a couple of
steps that are quite hard
and i'll show you some of them
and our idea was now okay these couple
of quite hard steps
can we go explain them in more detail
and and
here's an example so this is
not one of the very hard ones um but
this is one of the steps that's produced
um that could also
be explained in more detail because
if i were to explain to you what's going
on now
so we have derived and what's marked
here in the box is
a combination of implicit constraints
that's the reason why this follows
so what this says here is well daemon
doesn't eat farfalle or rottini
and 16 was not the prize of capolini or
tagliolini
so we can derive that damon didn't pay
16.
now the easiest way for me to explain it
would be well
yeah if damon would have paid 16 if this
would have been a yes
well in that case because
damon didn't take rotini but damon paid
16
then rotini cannot of course 16.
and because damon didn't take farfalle
and
they even paid 16 farfalle cannot have
paid 16
costs 16. yeah and so that means we have
a line of all
um minuses all impossibles
meaning that this is simply not gonna
work because 16
there was no poster that goes 16 anymore
yeah so there's some bijectivity
constraint violated here
this is how i would explain this so we
make the assumption
that we make a certain assumption and
and now
suddenly i can split this up into single
applications of transitivity and
bijectivity
by making this assumption it's making my
life a lot easier to explain it
and this explanation makes a lot more
sense than just saying
by these four squares and a combination
of these and these transitivity and
bijectivity constraints
this follows that's quite
difficult but if i didn't go explain it
into more detail yeah but what if
counterfactually what if this this were
different
then i can split it up into even smaller
steps to get to a contradiction
so that's what we added then on top of
the explanations too
to do this and here for this example
here
this is yeah in this visual interface if
you don't understand the step you can
say help
and uh say this one i don't understand
this derivation there was only one
and then it indeed splits it up it says
well yeah but from
if and this black square means this is
this counterfactual assumption if this
were the case
then um the 16 would not have
been there then rottini could not have
cost 16 just exactly
what i've i've been explaining and this
gives us a contradiction with
bijectivity
um one more
of the one of the more difficult
examples at a certain moment
this is found to be the um
correct sort of the next explanation
step
um oh by the way everything on the
website is
not necessarily optimal because this is
still with our
news based explanation but with some
heuristics to guide it towards
cheap explanations um so here there's no
optimality guarantee yet that's
um work in progress but so what it's
saying here is
oh the next simple thing to do is uh use
the fact that the person who ordered
tagliolini paid more than angie
and this is always possibly in
combination with some implicit
constraints
and the fact that ng didn't order
capellini
farfalle didn't cost four and agrollini
didn't cost 16 to derive that rotini
didn't cost 12.
now honestly if i see this
um i have no clue why that's true i mean
i believe the system because i know how
it works but
this is not helpful for me as a as a
human so it would take me a lot of time
to
understand why this is indeed a good
explanation step
luckily what the hell button says as
well
suppose hypothetically that rotini would
have cost 12.
then we can just start using bijectivity
constraints and see what we derive and
actually so um oh sorry
um we can now we can use this clue
the person who ordered taglini paid more
than ng
together with the fact that tagliolini
didn't cost 12 or 16
to derive that well tagliolini must have
cost eight
because tagalini cost more than uh
whatever
energy paid so there must be some
cheaper value there
and ng um
paid for actually because she paid less
antagolini
and then we can keep on going with your
transitivity this
typical triangular pattern ng page four
four was not linked to farfalle was not
the price of farfalle so angie didn't
have her vale
and you didn't have rotini and here it's
a big
activity constraint that derives uh
tagliolini cost eight
oh no sorry we already had this check
mark
it cost eight so it doesn't cost uh so
nothing else costs eight
the orange ones are the ones that are
derived um
and we can keep on going with basically
these simple steps
completing this and at a certain moment
we find a contradiction with
a transitivity constraint because
angie didn't uh angie paid four
four was the cost of cappellini but
angie didn't take up cappellini
so we get a contradiction so our
original assumption
was wrong so and this is here
jakob you were referring to this
shallowness so this is not shallow at
all anymore
but of course the good thing is that
we solve the memory problem in the sense
that a human reasoner to do this kind of
reasoning
this shallowness is maybe important
because of
remembering everything correctly if
you're not writing everything down
and yeah the steps are a bit more
trustworthy now but still this is quite
a difficult thing to derive next
um so
and that's basically what we do with the
with an asset explanations
so for certain steps we will
produce a nested explanation and what we
do basically to
to um to decide for which steps we do it
well we try to produce
an asset explanation for all steps but
the tool will only visualize it
in case the hardest step
in the nested explanation
is not as hard as the original step that
it's trying to explain
yeah because that can sometimes happen
if you're if your
step is just too simple saying i use a
symbol but simple by
activity constraint to derive that if
um well let's just take an example
i use where we use bijectivity
constraint here i use a single byte
activity constraint to derive that if
16 was the price of farfalle then
nothing else was the price of farfalle
if i go try to explain this in a nested
fashion well what if
um four was was the price of farfalle
then i'm just going to get well
contradiction with this big activity
constraint
and it's going to be as hard as my
original step so so in that case
you will see that the hell button
doesn't work because we tried to produce
an asset explanation
but we judged the hardest step in there
is as difficult as what you're trying to
explain so we're just not gonna give it
to you
and so to conclude um
so what i i showed you today is well
quite a young research project we're
still
there's still lots of angles to be
tackled here
but the overall goal is to provide
explanations that are somewhat human
understandable
or not not yet at least going all the
way to
to uh so we didn't do any experiments
with humans yet well we're not going
there yet
but it's it's an option to to consider
this as well
um and for now we've been focusing in on
splitting um certain derivations up in
in small comprehensible steps um
yeah a bit at explaining them at
different levels of detail
in the context of these asset
explanations you could also
go go further still and and say well
um within an asset explanation introduce
another
level of nesting but what you're done
basically doing is
yeah having some search uh
developing a complete search tree in the
end
and of course then the question is how
long can a user
really follow this
what we also saw is that there were some
new
algorithmic needs showing up that is
computing these focuses
this optimal constraint that is set
unsatisfiable subsets
and we demonstrate it on logic grid
puzzles as for
potential use cases of this kind of tool
um we envisioned that it could be used
to teach
human certain how to solve certain
problems like here this zebra puzzle
someone who's never seen them can can
look at this kind of
produced solutions to to
learn new problem-solving strategies
also probably to quantify difficulties
of a problem because
if we're if we can somehow measure
correctly how
difficult certain steps are then we
could quantify
problem difficulty or in an interactive
fashion
with the help button that while a user
is solving it gives you a hint about
well look at this clue because this is a
clue that's going to give you a next
simple step in more
let's say interesting scenarios
we believe this could also be used in
interactive configuration
or planning or scheduling tools where
there's some human some expert scheduler
doing the scheduling but assisted by a
computer who basically is doing
lots of smart propagation for him and
and um
showing him the consequences of their
choices
so in this setting it might sometimes
happen
that this expert scheduler thinks hey so
i selected certain things and now
suddenly i can no longer schedule this
course
in that lecture hall why is that explain
it to me
explain to me why you derived this and
then this kind of explanations might
come in handy
also at the time of the development of
the actual knowledge base
underlying such a system it might be
useful to see ah yeah
this constraint that i entered is
actually
that we're using now to explain
something is actually
how one that doesn't have to be enforced
so we're gonna disable this one so this
kind of interactivity
these explanations could also show up
some avenues for future work
would be well this has been mentioned a
couple of times already how can we
learn this optimization function and so
this
how to quantify difficulty of a step
basically
or could we also somehow know at which
level of abstraction to explain things
and level of abstraction can mean
two things here i can can refer to these
nested explanations but can also mean to
to
which vocabulary do we give the user do
we use to to explain things
uh so which literals can be used in the
explanation and which cannot we touched
upon this already
we also plan to look into explaining
optimization so explaining if we're
really
tackling optimization problems there's
lots of different types of
why questions that show up in this will
for instance um and this has been
studied quite
a bit in the context of explainable
planning already explainable
um ai planning um but you have these
these contrastive questions like why why
not this
so you're giving me some optimal
solution but why is this not in there
and then we can explain maybe you can
explain why it's still in there maybe
there's an alternative solution where it
is
but or what if i what if i change that
how much version does my solution get
actually there's a whole range of
questions that you can ask
and on the one hand we want to look into
what is this range of questions can we
come up with interesting solutions there
and on the other hand
can we make this efficient can we make
this scale
to an extent that it's really usable in
the kind of interactive problems that we
were talking about
and can we make all these these
algorithms possibly incremental to make
it even
even faster um these are some avenues
for future work
but there there are plenty more showing
up often so um
that concludes my talk if there are any
more questions i would be
very happy to answer them
so let me first on behalf of everybody
thank you for uh for a lovely
uh presentation this is great um
i certainly do have a few questions but
i should
give um a chance to others to chime in
first maybe if there
are any questions from the audience
um or while people in the audience are
are thinking so
so um you sketch
different user cases just out of
curiosity how how far do you think this
would be from a
like a scenario where you would actually
use it for well maybe not
these kind of cute puzzles but for for
some of the application areas you were
thinking about
um so is it more at the level of like
really foundational technology
development
we are still quite far from trying it
out on on
a real application say but
it is our plan to do this in a year or
two
say to to really go towards
some interactive scheduling for instance
and to to really try it out there
um so
what what we've been discussing today is
basically only
explaining the the propagation such a
system does
and and the question will arise well if
we if we
throw industrial problems at it much
larger than this kind of puzzles that
we're
throwing at it now how efficient will it
be
but of course the good thing is that
maybe
the propagation mechanisms used in in
in these systems might be weaker than
what we're doing now
basically computing the intersection of
all the models um
so in that sense there is some hope that
there's if there's not too much to
explain at
one um in one step
that this could still be doable but we
didn't test it yet but it's certainly on
the
planning to test this on more realistic
scenarios but
we didn't really start yet so
so one one question i was thinking about
also would you mention for instance like
scheduling problems or why one can
envision other
other constraints problems which have
two steps for the
user is first helping you to model the
problem
and then gets a solution back and then
maybe the original
user says no this is not what i was
looking for i mean i'm sorry but
this solution just doesn't make sense
say a scheduling of of
crew or whatever and like could you
potentially use this to
like say well you know what's wrong i
mean maybe i set my cost functions
incorrectly so that
the solver was prioritizing like i can
realize that
where on the path from modeling to
solution did we go wrong because this
was not the solution intuitively i was
looking for
um yeah so so this is i guess related to
this second point here so that
um so until now we only take out the
question
why do all of these things follow from
from my my model basically um
but we didn't look at other types of
questions yet so
i think what you're saying now is it's
more a kind of
contrastive question especially if you
if you would give some
some argument as to what's wrong not
just this is not a solution i expect but
but maybe
[Music]
why did this not happen in my solution
why are you suddenly
switching things completely up i mean i
don't know say you're
you're having a scheduling problem and i
you know the way the scheduling
algorithm
put out my summer vacation was like
truly terrible
i really want to click at it and say
what what on earth are the constraints
that forced you to put all
of my big you know all of my summer
vacation in december i mean that's a
terrible decision
um and then your algorithm will say aha
but this was because
because because uh this reason you
couldn't go in january and this reason
uh
indeed so that that kind of that kind of
thing
um might be possible if he was really
with what we have now if he was really
forced to put everything in december
and of course if he chose to put certain
things in december
then then uh we cannot explain it yet so
if there was
a choice and it didn't really matter and
and this
can happen if you just have a very bad
optimization function there
if you if you said basically i don't
care just plan it whenever and then you
you run
solve and then your schedule says
everything planned in december and then
you get angry
then it was basically an arbitrary
choice and we're not doing anything with
that yet um
yeah another thing i was just
thinking about i don't know if it makes
sense but but so
we've had other seminars in this and
other seminar series on
on certified algorithms and proof
logging we have for instance this famous
pythagorean triple uh problem that says
that you cannot color the
the integers black and white to avoid
monochromatic pythagorean triples and
you just get this big big big proof
that is really just a syntactic object
and the question is could you use these
kind of ideas to somehow you know
probe the proof and maybe get some sense
as to
okay like why
why are we running on into
contradictions at this point why is this
construction not possible please please
explain to me which
which constraints come into play
so my feeling is that there might be
some nice relation between
between the two um but i cannot really
pinpoint exactly there
but i i somehow have the feeling that
that
there are things to be learned in both
directions for instance if we could
if we could construct some i'll say
computer readable proof
and maybe we can abstract it
if we have some user vocabulary symbols
he knows and then we have a computer
readable proof that uses all the
auxiliary variables as well
maybe we can abstract a human
understandable proof from it
and that's uncertified or something else
that might
be useful is that we go certify all of
our steps so we're now saying well
here's a sequence of
explanations and the sequence at a high
level
can be followed by a human but maybe
it's also useful for him
to have the guarantee and that each step
is certified so there's another
possible interaction between the two um
but i have told a little bit about this
but not
uh so long yet but my feeling is that
there might be some nice
um correspondences
we're just catering to a different
audience basically
how much did you think about like
what methods of reasoning does one want
in the propagator
like what do we want the propagator to
understand i mean
we talked a little bit about symmetries
um should counting arguments like come
into play
or or what kind of what are your
thoughts on how much did you think about
like the underlying reasoning engine in
some sense
um so the engine that that derives at
certain things
follow actually what we did now is
completely agnostic of what this
propagator can do
if you have a very strong
propagation mechanism and you um
so basically i always used entailment
this entailed but you can just
replace it everywhere by um
by propagation can derive that with any
propagation mechanism you want
and and the steps don't work of course
and
that might also be interesting for from
of a human i mean if you make your
propagation mechanisms
weaker you get you might get closer to
the or if you get them at the right
level for the human basically
the kind of if you can match your
propagation mechanisms to what a human
can do and you say well from this
constraint
this fact follows then the human will
say okay because i
i can do the same type of reasoning as
this propagator and indeed it follows
well if you have a super strong
propagator that
combines the couple of clues together
and from these clues together
this follows the human might be
perplexed they might need some might
need this form of of nesting um
but so this has not yet been one of our
concerns
uh the actual propagation mechanism
i see so i don't
see i guess the finally the final call
for
questions from other parts of the
audience uh while i ask
what i believe is my final question
maybe
um so so far in this in
these experiments that you run how much
of an issue is is the
actual computational hardness that the
problems actually get
hard to crunch or this is like the
problem so far has been elsewhere or
um so with our original implementation
we really
uh even on these these puzzles already
we we bumped onto the problem that for
certain puzzles it took
hours to produce his explanation and and
um so
while it wouldn't take me hours to solve
this puzzle
so in that sense this was a bit
yeah is it clear what is there some kind
of hard problem or just
unfortunate algorithmic choices or like
um
well no this ocus problem is at least
hard on the second level of the
polynomial hierarchy
i think it it will just be um
what is it sigma p2 complete i think but
it's at least hard on the on the second
level of the polynomial hierarchy so
there is some hard problem involved
there
um and to generate an entire sequence
we're doing this as many times worst
cases there are literals also
solving this type of problem so we we're
yeah if our problem if our problems
scale up too much we will we will get
into trouble with that possibly
um so
and i think to really to really feel
this we just need to try it
we just need to try larger instances and
see whether these problems really show
up and then
looking at approximate algorithms is
also um
on our agenda to really make it scale
still
to maybe sacrifice optimality again
but i have some guarantee of being close
to optimal
um and
yeah to live with that i guess if
you do this on on interactive scheduling
problems and so on you might be able to
lift with a good enough explanation
instead of having the guarantee it's
optimal with respect to this function
i see that some hands uh popped up in
the meanwhile
uh ah yes that's interesting so
there's a hand up by carlos please feel
free to just unmute and ask your
question carlos
okay uh yes i have a question about your
uh can you hear me yeah i can hear you
very well
you're still look muted uh zoom still
tells me you're muted but
i believe that you're talking so okay
good so i have a question about your
introduction
so you were mentioning that more or less
that we should
work on richard or higher formalisms
to don't lose the structure
while we are converting if we are
converted to cnf
there is some strata that we are going
to lose okay
so that's fair enough this is actually
this is the case all the time that we
lose that structure but
what about the structure that the user
is not aware of so
what worries me is that the important
structure is that the stratos that the
user
is not able to see so it is placing some
constraints together
and then because of the conjunction of
these constraints
it arises a new structure that the user
is not going to see
but with some pre-processing techniques
and detection techniques in the
cnf you can derive that structure also
when you take some decisions and you
generate a new sub problem
you can't derive that structure but the
user is not aware of that
so there is a simple example you take
the old difficult constraint
you take some decisions and then you see
a pigeon hole
okay so this is a very simple example so
so i was wondering this is like
programming in a high-level language
like python and doing some
optimizations at the level of assembly
you know
so maybe you want to have both things
that was my message
yeah i think you definitely want to have
both things
and what you definitely also want i
think is detecting the structure
at a high level so the structure that
the human is not aware of that's maybe
not the case when you do the choices and
then end up with the pigeon hole but
but if there are a couple of all
difference and you can combine them
already
just by looking at them you can see some
structure that the user might not be
aware of but
that's actually there if you can see it
at a high level it's probably
easier in the sense that you're
basically you're you're not paying for
your data complexity
you're only looking at your high level
specification and you can ignore your
problem size and whatever you can derive
from that is already nice to have
um and um so i absolutely agree i think
i think we should have both
but certain things um
yeah that i've been doing i always felt
like
well i'm really trying to detect
something that
was there in the first place the kind of
symmetries we've been looking at this
structure
must have been there it must have been
visible in the first order
representation
but it just got lost and and it feels
like a shame
to let this structure disappear
but of course there are instances where
you
cannot just see it and then detection
mechanisms are still needed
okay thanks a lot great question um
do we have i guess this is the final
chance
at least for today to ask more questions
to bart
before we officially declare
this seminar to be
over i should mention as the link is in
the chat that
registered workshop participants are
welcome
to meet in gather town at the simon's
institute after the workshop um
so but i think uh i don't see any more
questions
and uh we've certainly kept you working
for
for uh quite a while bart so so thanks
so much again for a wonderful seminar
thanks for the invitation it was nice to
be here okay
thank you so much for today bye-bye bye